our ongoing series issues that matter
explores the challenges that affect our
country today we focus this morning on
gender discrimination in the workplace
that confessed at Ellen Powell made
headlines during her 2015 gender
discrimination trial it was against
Silicon Valley venture capital firm
Kleiner Perkins Caufield & Byers now
claimed in the 16 million dollar lawsuit
that she experienced bias as an employee
she also said she was overlooked for
promotions and suffered retaliation
after she complained in the interest of
full disclosure I have a longtime
business and professional relationship
with kleiner perkins and their people
and in fact i have known ellen Powell
since I'm about 10 years tell me what
you hope to accomplish let's just point
out real quickly that the case became
one of the most prominent lawsuits of
its kind in Silicon Valley POW lost to
the suit but she helped revolutionize
the national conversation about gender
equality in the tech industry and other
fields she reveals her story for the
first time in a new memoir called reset
my fight for inclusion and lasting
change Ellen Pao welcome thank you for
having me let's follow on just what
Charlie was just about to ask you about
first describe what you think was the
type of discrimination that you faced at
the company it was two things it was one
the broader people not getting women not
getting promoted people of color not
getting hired and it was also the
smaller thing so it's being asked to get
the coffee being asked to babysit you
know partners kids being asked to take
notes being you know only woman being
asked to take notes so it was the
broader not being able to get promoted
but it was also being treated as a
second-class citizen and being asked to
do things that other people are not and
you said who men were not asked to do
those things men who were junior to you
were not asked to do those type of
things right right it was very much an
expectation that women were willing to
do that work and were the right people
to do that work it's your argument that
Silicon Valley needs to change faster
than it is or simply not changing I
don't think it's really changing I think
people will have seen the problem now
there's so many women and so many men
who have spoken up about it but in order
to really change you have to change
everything about the system right you're
bringing people in and assist
that interviews in a way that protects
the people who are ready there you bring
in your friends to your company it's a
very traditional way of hiring and you
need to open that up and figure out how
you can get other people in and then how
you can make them successful in a way
that's there there's a front page story
today in USA Today that quotes you
prominently about Asian women in
particular do you think that it is
different for Asian women they say that
you're often told a generic you often
told that you speak too softly you
should bring in a man that you're often
Asian women are mistaken for other women
on the team and that your proposition
all the time you think this is true I
think it's true I think it's different
from four different races and I think
the intersectionality plays a big role
and for Asians there's an expectation
especially for Asian women that you'll
be subservient that you're not going to
rock the boat that you're going to take
these second to your roles and just do
them happily and work really hard at
them I noticed Ellen after the lawsuit
and everything and you wrote in the new
york times you've had trouble finding
another job that you've been described
by people as fraud and greedy have you
dealt with that it's been you know I've
been lucky I've had people who have
reached out to me so people who have had
their own experiences and have said
they've connected to my story and they
thanked me you know in many different
ways for sharing my story and that has
been you know made this work rewarding
so the fact that people are finding
value in it and even if I had a hard
time finding a job there was a bigger
reason for what feels like to that after
you're lost that there became this
scrutiny really of Silicon Valley that
has led to everything from uber to I
mean a number of different companies
that scrutiny and women's leaking out to
because of your case I think that was
the reason for all of the change that I
spoke up and then you know dozens of
women have spoken up but why do you
think you lost the case so Ellen what
you laid out I thought was very
compelling in your book and the people
that you talked to why do you think you
lost a case and do you think they're
things you should ever could have done
differently I think people didn't
believe that it could happen and there
was also a set you know in the trial the
jury candidates who were who believed
that there was bias in tech we're all
kicked off the jury pool so you ended up
with a group of people who did not think
there was biasing
Tech and those people weren't able to
see it that's crazy about this for me
and is it somebody if you are a person a
business man or a woman you want to find
the smartest people you can to help you
achieve your results so discrimination
is is stupid yeah yeah
beyond wrong it's stupid you want to use
the talents of everybody yeah I think
there's a set of people who don't
believe that women and people of color
can can execute and can perform and work
the same way that other people can't so
there's a set that people of people who
think that people aren't doing there's
no evidence to prove yeah Charlie's
point though about it finding the best
people you were highly credentialed
Princeton undergrad at Harvard Law
School still there were things where
people question your intelligence and
you started to doubt yourself and I
think it's bias it's just people don't
think that women and and people of color
perform at the same level of regardless
of all their experience and regardless
of all their education they can't look
at the facts they have you know a lens
that just prevents them from letting
them 16 I think one of the nice things
you Brooke does it's called reset - it
includes tips for people who are are
underrepresented groups perhaps in
Silicon Valley what are some of those
tips I think one that's find a place
that is actually going to help you
succeed so you know if you're stuck in a
place where they don't give you those
opportunities where they you know ignore
that your experience and they put you in
a lower role try to get out if you can
and another one is you know speak up for
other people so speak up for yourself
speak up for other people when you can
and just really like make sure that
you're always learning make sure that
you know you can see that there's bias
and discrimination but also learn when
you can from the feedback that is
actually helpful what's happen to you
since you left planet Perkin oh it took
me a while to find a job I was very
lucky ish on wrong at read it hired me
for an executive role and then I worked
there for maybe a year and a half and
then they promoted me to CEO when you
Sean left I went and made a lot of
changes that read it so I got rid of
revenge porn I got rid of unauthorized
nude pictures and that sparked all of
the big companies to follow which was
great but then I also tried to get rid
of some of the
sites that were harassing individuals
and that caused a lot of controversy I
ended up getting asked to leave and then
after a year and a half during which
time I wrote the book I ended up joining
the Cape or Center and working as chief
diversity and inclusion officer I
started a nonprofit called Project
include which is designed to help
everyone get a fair chance in tech and
and and now I'm here with you and
kleiner perkins says this about you that
your lawsuit is without merit
and that the firm is committed to
supporting women and minorities in the
tech industry you're advised not to
bring the lawsuit by other women but you
did it anyway regrets about that not at
all I mean from all the support that
I've received and from the change that
I'm starting to see in perceptions of
how people are treated it's been you
know it's it's been worth it and you've
started a big discussion on this island
pal thank you so much we really
appreciate it thank you for having me
good to see you reset is on sale today